[Aplausos]
un amigo mío muy sabio él me dijo la
lechuga no es saludable le dice solo y
no te contesta
si los rays no tiene gracia
a partir de ese momento ese chiste entra
a formar parte de mi top 3 de chistes
favoritos junto al de cariño que la
cisterna vuelva a perder bueno pero dile
que lo importante es participar
hay quien dice que tengo un amor
infantil hay quien dice que tengo humor
absurdo y me llama la atención cómo la
gente equipara estos dos términos no lo
infantil lo absurdo como como si los
niños fuesen absurdos no cuando
realmente son los niños los que nos dan
tantas lecciones a los adultos verdad yo
de los niños he aprendido mucho
muchísimo he aprendido a ser humilde
como un niño cuando no sabe algo y
pregunta he aprendido a dejar volar mi
imaginación como un niño con un folio
blanco delante he aprendido a vencer mis
miedos sociales como un niño que dice lo
que piensa sin importarle lo que piensen
los demás he aprendido a perdonar como
un niño que se enfada con otro pero a
los 5 minutos estamos viendo a jugar en
el parque he aprendido a aprovechar las
palomitas que caen al suelo en el cine
que es una pena que se desperdicien por
dios
en resumen he aprendido mucho muchísimo
muchísimo de los niños y todavía todavía
me queda mucho por aprender y hoy quiero
hablaros de una de las actividades que
los niños más adoran y de las que muchos
adultos rehúyen precisamente por
considerarla algo infantil estoy
hablando de jugar
mi nombre es francisco lorenzo y mi
trabajo consiste en hacer fácil lo
difícil como lo hago enseñando a la
gente a utilizar el funcionamiento
natural de su cerebro para conseguir
cosas como aumentar los ingresos a
partir del pensamiento creativo ser más
persuasivos
perder el miedo a hablar en público y un
largo etcétera con el que no tener en el
y siempre siempre en todas las
formaciones que imparto sean de
negociación o de marketing sean para
niños o para adultos sean sobre
creatividad sean individuales o
colectivas sean para particulares o para
empresas siempre siempre siempre utilizo
algún juego como herramienta hoy os he
traído una selección de bueno de algunos
juegos que suelo utilizar
el primero de ellos es el pulso chino
para eso voy a pedir la colaboración de
javier vale
ahí está un aplauso para él por favor
vamos a ver las reglas del curso chino
en primer lugar ponemos por parejas
podéis poner por parejas por favor quién
es quién es querer jugar segunda regla y
agarrar las manos como podéis ver ahí
vale las manos derechas si sois diestros
las izquierdas y sois zurdos si unos
días que el otro zurdo
os aguantáis
y tercero y lo más lo más importante
moviendo sólo el pulgar nos vale mover
la muñeca calidad corazones en la cara
vale solo sólo moviendo el pulgar
intentar atrapar el pulgar del otro
la mayor cantidad posible de veces
entonces javier y yo os vamos a
acompañar
ahora mientras echáis el pulso chino
vale espera
ya vale
preparados listos dispuestos
por estos
vamos a ver
lo que estábamos haciendo está está bien
hecho o deberíamos hacer mejor esto otro
vamos a ver cuál era el objetivo del
juego atrapar el pulgar del otro la
mayor cantidad posible de celo poner
bien clarito porque entonces nos
centramos tanto en atrapar lo más veces
que el otro voy a hablar un poco sobre
esto vamos a despedir a muchos por favor
[Aplausos]
este pulso chino lo utilizo en mis
formaciones de trabajo colaborativo y
tiene el increíble poder de cambiar la
mentalidad de la gente para hacerle ver
que muchas veces nuestro cerebro tiende
tanto a la competición que no ve que
colaborando las dos partes pueden
conseguir más beneficios que porque por
separado por ejemplo una empresa que
quiere aumentar sus ventas con quién
tiene que echar pulsos chinos
competitivos es con otras empresas de su
sector con su competencia directa
mientras que sus trabajadores su equipo
interno deben colaborar entre sí
ayudarse no pisarse los unos a los otros
y que si el equipo en conjunto pueda
conseguir la mayor cantidad posible de
puntos cuando estamos echando un pulso
chino cada pareja era una empresa y sólo
aquellas que en la que sus integrantes
colaboraron consiguieron más puntos que
las demás y este es uno de los
es un ejemplo de uno de los beneficios
más importantes del juego la capacidad
para extrapolar lecciones a la vida real
fijaos en lo que hemos hecho hemos
aprendido una lección sobre trabajo
colaborativo a partir del juego del
curso chino es decir los hemos conectado
y precisamente desde este tipo de
conexión es de lo que os quiero hablar a
continuación
william plomer decía que la creatividad
es la capacidad de conectar lo que
aparentemente no está conectado por
ejemplo que conexión hay entre un topo y
un cirujano en principio parece que
ninguna pero si lo pensamos un poco nos
damos cuenta de que el topo acepto pero
si el cirujano puesto pero
e
lo que
[Aplausos]
lo que pasa lo que pasa es que para
encontrar este tipo de asociaciones hay
que tener desarrollada la habilidad de
conexión vale y para eso os voy a
enseñar el juego que yo suelo utilizar
para entrenar estabilidad se llama
código secreto es un juego por equipos
que en el año 2016 en el premio espy el
design es alemán y se es así que cómo se
juega
sencillamente se colocan 25 cartas sobre
la mesa vale en forma de esta cuadrícula
de 5 x 5 cada carta tiene una palabra y
el juego nos va diciendo qué palabras
tenemos que conseguir que nuestro equipo
adivine dándoles un código secreto
formado por una palabra y por un número
no hay saber mejor con un ejemplo
supongamos que vosotros sois soy mi
equipo vale y yo os doy el código
secreto animal 3
una palabra y un número vale eso qué
significa significa que entre estas 25
cartas hay tres de ellas que están
conectadas de alguna forma con la
palabra animal y que si lo pensáis un
poco pues no os llevará mucho tiempo
descubrir que son caracol lobo y llama
fácil no vale ahora vamos a verlo desde
el punto de vista de la persona que
discurre en la conexión vale
supongamos que tenéis que conectar estas
dos palabras cuadro y polo que código
secreto podréis utilizar por ejemplo
podéis utilizar marco dos porque los
cuadros están en marcos y los grupos por
marco polo
supongamos que tenemos que conectar
ahora estas cuatro palabras cuadro golpe
puente y manga esta ya es un poquito más
complicada hay que empieza que es
imposible conectar cuatro palabras que
ya son muchas pero en realidad si lo
pensamos un poquito también nos damos
cuenta de que hay un código secreto que
es ladrón 4 vale los ladrones una de las
cosas más valiosas que roban son los
cuadros cuando roban están dando un
golpe si roban un coche hacen un puente
y un ladrón que hace fin de cuentas
manga vale
bien si tuviéramos que conectar estos
tres último ejemplo música caracol y
sifón como podríamos conectarlos esto es
un poquito más difícil pero si nos damos
cuenta vemos que podemos conectarlas con
el código secreto despacito 3 vale el
caracol anda despacito despacito son
nuevo fuerte las discotecas este verano
vales música
depende a qué le pregunte
y que encanta despacito luis fonsi vale
si repites fonsi muchas veces como si
fonsy fonsy fonsys
[Aplausos]
ahora mismo puedo ir pensando este tío
se llama la pinza que no está colgada en
el tendedero pero no sé si pero lo que
quiero decir que esto tiene una
importancia una relevancia varios voy a
poner un ejemplo había una empresa
que sufría las quejas de sus clientes y
de sus trabajadores porque los
ascensores que tenían iban muy lentos
entonces que usaban el botón y llegaba a
la cabina pues la espera se les hacía
eterna se reunió el equipo de dirección
y para encontrar una solución y la
primera que salió como es obvio fue la
de vamos aumentar la velocidad de los
ascensores es decir si el problema son
las quejas de los clientes por culpa de
los ascensores lentos si queremos que la
gente deje de quejarse vamos a poner
ascensores rápidos
qué pasa que aumentar la velocidad de
los ascensores suponía un tiempo de
obras que obligaría a la gente a subir
por las escaleras igual se cambiaban
todavía más exigieron los presupuestos
pero era un poco latoso entonces sigue
una persona que dijo mira lo que vamos a
hacer es colocar espejos a los lados de
las puertas de los ascensores lo
hicieron y a partir de ese momento la
gente después de pulsar el botón
mientras la cabina llevaba pues empezaba
a mirar al espejo ajustarse el nueva
corbata a peinarse el flequillo vale con
lo cual cuando la cabina llevaba llegaba
pues ya no se nos había dado cuenta
el resultado fue que las quejas se
redujeron en un 80% que hizo la persona
a la que se le ocurrió esta solución
sencillamente se saltó la conexión obvia
y conecto la ausencia de quejas con los
ascensores lentos vale es decir que lo
único que hay que hizo a partir de ese
momento fue discurrir y decir vale cómo
puedo conseguir que la gente deje de
quejarse manteniendo la velocidad de los
de los ascensores vale esto es un
ejemplo de conexión útil que se puede
utilizar en la vida real
y seguir hablando de otro juego que
también tiene mucha miga que es google
translate sé que mucha gente odia el
google translate por lo mal que traduce
y también muchos estaréis pensando que
no es un juego vale no fue creado para
ser un juego pero si se puede utilizar
como como juego vale es distinto como lo
utilizo yo vale yo entabló conversación
en inglés con el alumno en plan hello
igual hasta que
hasta que llega un punto en el que el
alumno quiere decir algo en inglés
díselo al google translate él se lo dice
con el reconocedor de voz en español
activado y voy a cerrar la ventana en el
google translate se lo traduce por
escrito yo ahí estoy atento por si
vuestras listas hace de las suyas y se
lo traduce mal detentó para que la
traducción esté bien hecha y yo le digo
vale ahora con el audio le pongo el
audio y el vuelto se dice i'm gone to
lose de windows vale y entonces el
alumno tiene tres intentos o más o menos
en función de la edad y del nivel que
tenga para conseguir que el google
translate le entienda con el reconocedor
de voz en inglés activado ahora lo
entiendo
vale lo que lo que aprenden con este
método ya le gustaría los libros de
inglés es interactivo con lo cual el
nivel de implicación y de recuerdo es
muchísimo mayor se aprende vocabulario
se aprende escucha se aprende y
pronunciación y lo que se divierten
fijados estos son algunos ejemplos vale
vale una vez que el alumno bueno quería
decirle al google translate i want me
with potatoes que significa quiero carne
con patatas
pronunciación no fue buena del todo lo
que entendió el google translate fue
will meet with potatoes que significa me
reuniré con las patatas
otro ejemplo otro alumno le dijo al
google translate iloveyou entras yo que
significa te quiero y confío en ti una
frase bonita verdad con sentimiento
bueno pues tuvo que venir el gol tras
letras para hallarla y le entendió a él
of war atrás que se podría traducir como
algo así como me encanta que seas basura
seguimos otro juego que es utilizar
mucho es el sum y vale quien diseñó este
juego tuvo la sencilla pero brillante
idea de crear un scrabble con números en
vez de con letras es decir que en vez de
hacer palabras lo que hay que hacer son
multiplicaciones sumas restas y
divisiones entre cruzadas vamos a ver
cuántos alumnos hay que aborrecen el
cálculo en el colegio cuántos adultos
hay que no recuerdan las tablas de
multiplicar vale entonces porque en vez
de machacar los y machacarnos con los
dichosos cuadernillos rubio porque no
echamos unas partidas a estos juegos y
de paso que desarrollamos nuestro
cálculo mental nos divertimos
un último ejemplo que quiero destacar en
caja palabras este lo podéis encontrar
online en caja palabras puntocom y una
derivación del vocal y es sencillamente
una sopa de letras vitaminada en la que
hay que encontrar palabras escondidas
siguiendo dos reglas la primera de ellas
es que una una letra puede unirse a otra
adyacente en vertical horizontal o
diagonal y la otra es que no se puede
utilizar en la misma palabra la misma
casilla dos veces vale un ejemplo para
que lo veáis mejor si empezamos por la
tf y bajamos en diagonal adyacente hasta
la vale en horizontal obtenemos la
palabra tuya otro ejemplo un poco más
complicado como veis aquí si vamos yendo
de letra en letras yacente
consecutivamente formamos la palabra
atenea bien aquí quiero haceros dos
preguntas primera cuántos de vosotros
habéis intentado o estáis intentando
buscar palabras aquí escondidas vale
esto demuestra que tenemos tan arraigado
el juego en nuestra naturaleza en
nuestro cerebro que rehuir de él tiene
todavía menos sentido y en segundo lugar
la segunda pregunta para qué creéis que
se puede utilizar está este juego en la
vida real
cristo lo diga
no lo voy a decir porque no lo voy a
decir porque quiero que vosotros pongáis
en marcha nuestra habilidad de conexión
y vuestro pensamiento creativo y que
saquéis una de las respuestas una de las
miles de respuestas que hay bueno podría
seguir hablando de juegos durante horas
y horas pero me va tocando terminar
así que nada yo espero que estos minutos
que me habéis dedicado en estos minutos
pues os haya podido dar una serie de
información y que le deis una
oportunidad al juego y el pensamiento
creativo para ayudaros a hacer fácil lo
difícil y antes de terminar me gustaría
aclarar una duda que igual quedó quedó
por ahí que es cuál es el tercer chiste
de mi top 3 de chistes favoritos es pues
es ese es en el que el grumete se acerca
el capitán y le dice el capitán se
aproximan 15 carabelas por estribor una
flota grumete no flotan todas
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]